here's something funny to wrap today up
yesterday was former president donald
trump's 75th
birthday he celebrated of course like
anyone else at one of his own clubs
wearing a suit with all the other men
wearing suits
and everybody was referring to him as
sir and mr
president there's nothing more
heartwarming and convivial and familiar
than um getting people to wear suits and
say
happy birthday sir mr president and um
it really looks like a hostage video i
have to show you this
when when they're singing him happy
birthday
this looks like when all the parents
tell their kids i don't care if you
don't like little donny
you have to go to the party and you've
got to behave
because his parents are important people
and i'm not going to be embarrassed
check this out
happy birthday dear mr president that's
a real family and friends gathering huh
you hear that and if you don't run again
we are going to sing to you
every year what would you tell donald
trump
on his 75th birthday well what
newsmax did is send a guy with a mic
out to ask people and lo and behold
everyone they talk to
loves trump you've got to see this
donald trump's 75th birthday
or james klug went out to get birthday
greetings james yeah
what's going on everyone james klug here
today if you're allergic to cringe i
would tune away right now
president donald trump's birthday and
we're gonna ask people in huntington
beach
if they have a message for him yeah
today is donald trump's birthday do you
have a message for him
all right happy happy happy birthday and
i hope i see him back
do you have a message for him yeah i
wish him a great birthday i hope he's
doing well i hope with all the
this public hate going on it's not
getting to him and uh he's out there
killing it on the golf course
yeah why is this so cringy like why is
this so
painful to watch tell me why birthday
trump
and i hope he comes back in 2024. uh
happy birthday mr trump and go out and
shoot the low 70s today bye happy
birthday
happy birthday we love the guy he's
awesome yup
hawaii loves him he hugs the flag that's
what i love about him
today is donald trump's birthday do you
guys have a message from love you donald
trump
oh my gosh our favorite news show our
favorite news show newsmax is here what
an incredible day
it's donald trump's birthday today do
you have a message for everybody happy
birthday happy birthday we miss you
oh my gosh happy birthday donald happy
birthday happy birthday happy birthday
hope you're doing well i'm not going to
wish you a happy birthday because
i think you're a jerk and i think you
should be in jail
there you go now that this woman i like
this is a that's a nice one the laws
that you broke what law specifically
of course you would ask me that for the
details
for the details i don't sorry i don't
have any details
sorry it makes sense if you could get
him one gift what would you get him
come back i can't afford to buy him
anything but maybe we could print out a
photo of him hugging the flag
raja you could sign it oh he'll sign a
gift to me yeah so
just just painful guys i mean that is a
segment that uh you know
i can't in good countenance show you any
more of that so it's a re i might end up
at urgent care from how hard i cringed
uh donald trump now 75
and of course the only real practical
consideration is
do we really think that 70 80 is going
to run for president uh
maybe maybe not we will wait and see one
of our sponsors is
rise the science-based app that makes it
easy to improve your sleep
and your daily energy and rise uses two
core principles that have emerged from
sleep science
one is sleep debt as an idea of how much
sleep you owe
your body and circadian rhythms
dictating
your energy levels and rise helps you
figure out your sleep needs helps you
track your sleep debt
every morning rise tells you how long
you'll probably be groggy
when your high energy time will be when
you should start winding down for bed
to optimize your sleep and so you can
make science-based improvements to 16
different sleep habits to improve your
daytime energy
i've been using rise myself on my phone
i started noticing higher quality sleep
in a few nights
and it's allowed me to just better
understand how my energy levels
correspond with my sleep
and i've had a really great experience
with it my audience can try rise
for free for an entire week by going to
science dot com slash pacman the link is
right underneath this video